[Music]  ladies and gentlemen  i present to you  the eighth wonder of the world  [Music]  [Applause]  hello pups  jumping keepers  an almost real boy  [Music]  turn around let me get a look at you  i will be right here when you get back  pinocchio is running around loose  without a conscience can you imagine the  trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't  want that on my conscience everybody  who's anybody wants to be a somebody but  i want to be real why on earth would you  want to be real when you can be  famous  [Music]  nokia should have been home by now  you won't be a puppet anymore  that's for sure  [Music]  pinocchio  be brave  truthful  non-selfish  [Music]  you will always be my real boy  a lie can really change a person pinocks  oh what's happening jiminy looks like  some sort of fairy magic  kind of on the nose if you ask me  [Music]  you